anyone who's going to spend the time and
effort to learn a language should
understand how the process works and
there is no better explainer than
stephen krashen hi there steve kaufman
here today
today i'm going to talk about stephen
krashen
and the theory of language acquisition
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notification notification and if you
follow me on uh a podcast service please
leave a review i appreciate it
so uh i mentioned stephen crash in in
one of my previous videos and i said
that he has put out uh a book
finn book
uh which really he says all there is
that we need to know about language
acquisition and someone asked what is
the book well actually there are quite a
few books and i would recommend that
people google for stephen krashen go to
his website and you'll find all kinds of
free material and i think it's important
for people who are interested to learn
you know a language interested in
language learning that they understand
how the process works and the best
explainer of how we learn languages in
my opinion by far is stephen krashen and
uh so i was gonna i thought i would
do one or several videos where i walk
through
some of his explanations about language
learning so
this is a book that i got in taipei when
i was there i don't know 15 years ago
and he was presenting there and i didn't
know him but i listened to him
and it was kind of like a eureka moment
and i bought this book
so let's just start here
and it's not like i'm reading from the
bible but almost
so the principles of language
acquisition
first of all the following five
hypotheses you know explanations of how
we learn
are the core of current theory on
language acquisition first of all the
acquisition learning hypothesis
claims that we have two independent ways
of developing language ability
one is
language acquisition as a subconscious
process
and the second one is a deliberate
effort the way we learn in school
and his point is that we learn primarily
naturally
in a as a subconscious
process and that the rules and the
grammar that we learn at school don't
help us very much
the second hypothesis is the natural
order hypothesis
which states that there is a natural
order
with which we're going to acquire
the elements of a language
and there's a natural order
for acquiring certain elements of
grammar
and it doesn't necessarily relate to how
simple or complex
those particular grammar issues are and
it uses the example of the sort of
progressive form in english the ing i'm
going learning doing
versus the third person singular
which takes an s as we know
takes an s takes an s so
even though the idea that the third
person singular in the present tense
takes an s is a very simple concept it
takes a long time for most language
learners people learning english to
acquire whereas the ing form the
continuous or the progressive form is
acquired very early and studies have
shown that a number of issues in grammar
in different languages seem to be
acquired in the same order and it
doesn't really matter how much effort is
put into teaching these it's not because
something is taught that we acquire it
because there is a natural order
and so in the natural order is
not based on simplicity or complexity
it's immune to deliberate teaching
and so the and the corollary in a way is
that
you know the natural order is not the
teaching order
so you may still teach different things
but it's going to be acquired according
to this natural order
the third element of his language
acquisition theory
is the monitor hypothesis
and the conscious sort of teaching of
the language creates in us a monitor
here are the correct rules here is how
the language is spoken but he makes the
point that the monitor our knowledge of
grammar can make only a very small
contribution to language acquisition
because
there are so many rules of grammar and
so few people who know all the rules the
idea
that
the learner will know the rule when he
or she needs to use it will remember the
rule
if the learner spends their time and
effort on thinking about the rule and
i'm about to say this now let's think
about the rule is this correct they
won't be able to speak because it's just
simply too difficult to do
while speaking
so the monitor
if anything can actually inhibit
speaking
so the monitor
uh as a means of you know improving our
our
knowledge of a language is not very
effective
the next thing is the input or
comprehension hypothesis
we we learn languages when we understand
a message when we're interested in a
message and we understand a message
comprehensible input is the only thing
that works says krashen in language
acquisition we have tried grammar rules
we have tried repetition drills the
input hypothesis com
claims however that comprehending
messages is the only way language is
acquired
there is no individual variation in the
fundamental process of language
acquisition
and and then he goes on to explain that
we acquire this
language through
you know input
when we already have enough things that
we have already acquired so that i plus
one we we acquired that next thing that
we could learn can learn once we have
acquired sort of the previous things
and so we learn from context
and therefore the teaching method has to
be focused on giving learners
comprehensible input
now a corollary of the
input hypothesis is that talking is not
practicing in other words you can't
output your way to
language acquisition
it is the input that's going to give you
the language acquisition if you get
enough input then you will have that
situation of sort of n plus one because
you'll be getting so much input that
there will be elements there that you
are already familiar with that will
enable you then to learn some additional
elements with enough input
now immediately people are going to say
well when you first start you don't
understand anything
and so crashing in this book
explains how in a classroom
this sort of total physical response tpr
is a method in the classroom where the
teacher can simplify
the language content can use
gestures can use pictures can use a
whole range of things to help the
learner
start to get a toehold in the language
create that
n or he refers to it as i
so that incrementally additional things
can then be added to what is understood
i happen to believe that
with a system like link and people are
going to criticize me
but the idea that that we can create
that same sheltered environment even for
people who are not in a classroom
using say the many stories where there's
a lot of repetition of vocabulary you
can look words up you can listen again
you can read again
somewhere you have to get a start in the
language you have to get a start
initially nothing is comprehensible you
have to start to acquire little bits and
pieces so that you can then build on
that with additional things that start
to become comprehensible and so the
complexity of what you're listening to
gets greater and greater as you're able
to expand into new domains i i think
i'll stop it there he has a lot of
research to back up what he's saying but
i just think it's it's well worthwhile
anyone who's going to spend the time and
effort to learn a language should
understand how the process works and
there is no better explainer than
stephen krashen so whether it be this
particular book
or whether you simply go to his website
and download all of the free material
that's there i'll leave a link in the
description box i i very much suggest
you do it
and
i think armed with this sense of how we
learn languages
even if we think we're not progressing
it's obvious from what crashing rights
based on all of his research and
experience as long as we continue to
expose ourselves to the language we will
continue to gradually improve
okay i thought i'd just bring you up to
date on on where you can get some more
information about stephen crash because
there were questions about that thank
you for listening